welcome back everyone to episode number
14 of the beginner to master speedrun I
ended last episode on a 47 game win
streak so we'll try and keep it going
today my current ELO is
972 and I think the goal is to break a
thousand so we'll see if I can do that
this episode let's hop into the
10-minute pool and first game playing e
got this play
E4 and and we'll stick with the standard
openings we have a Petrov defense also
known as a Russian uh now this could go
into a Stafford Gambit if I take the
pawn and black plays Knight
C6 but generally the best move is to
take the
pawn I'll see what my opponent wants to
do
here the main line is Pawn
D6 I did have a game in the series that
featured Knight takes E4 which is a
typical mistake which walks into Queen
E2 but we do see a Stafford Gambit man
the first Stafford of the whole series
and I'm not the one who's playing it as
black um I mean against the
Stafford I feel kind of bad because I'm
just going to play the
reputation uh but against the Stafford
you do have to be very very careful as
white uh of course black wants to take
the pawn there's Knight C3 and D3 which
are the two main moves I'm going to play
D3 as a safer
move and now Bishop 2
C5 and like one of the reasons why the
Stafford is so
popular partly because my videoos on it
but also because um there's just so many
traps that white can fall into like E5
already loses to Knight E4 Knight C3
runs into Knight G4 Bishop G G5 there's
a crazy tactic Knight takes E4 and then
black can oh no my queen uh so the best
move in this position is simply Bishop
E2 preventing Knight G4 trying to stop
all the the t o
shananigans and hopefully this will be
an instructive lesson on how to uh
actually refute the Stafford and avoid
all the tricky traps that white could
potentially fall
into now usually when I play this
position as black uh I like to play
H5 which sets up Knight
G4 and um yeah there's still a lot of
ways that white can go wrong from here
uh but there's a couple moves that are
typically recommended there's a lot of
videos on YouTube that cover the
reputation to the Stafford I think I
probably have a few videos my own
covering what I recommend for whites um
but the two moves are either C3 or H3 H3
just stops Knight G4 right away and C3
prepares
D4 uh in this case I'm going to play
H3 which I think is a more kind of
traditional safe move ensuring that
Knight G4 will not
happen um now there are a couple ways
black can try and be tricky here uh one
way is to play Queen
D4 another way is to play Queen
D6 I'm pretty sure my my most viewed
video on YouTube features this
line uh it's something like uh trapping
everyone with the same opening
trap and it features Queen D6 castling
and then Knight G4 and then there's
lines where white plays G3 preventing
Queen H2 Checkmate there's Queen takes
G3 because of the
pin
so yeah very often white will not end up
casting
kingside in this variation
um I am curious if my opponent knows
that they're playing me uh like you do
have to click on my profile to see that
it's a the authorized speedrun account
A6 is uh it's a little bit of a slow
move it does give room for the bishop to
retreat but also gives me time to carry
through with my own ideas and now I'm
going to play C3 very simply preparing
D4
okay black gaining space on the queen
side but I don't mind expanding in the
center and one of the nice things here
is because Black's committed to H5 this
Pawn can't move backwards and I can
happily put the bishop on
G5 I can't really be kicked by the H
Pawn meanwhile I am threatening to play
E5 to attack the pin
Knights so black
is already probably not in the best
position like I'm up a pawn I have the
center this is one reason why the
Stafford is
objectively not a great opening if if
white knows what to do against
it Queen D7 is actually not a bad move
escaping the PIN
and now if I play E5 the Knight can
either move to D5 or
E4 so I do have the option of taking
which does damage Black's
structure would provoke Pawn takes back
on
F6 and I also have the option of
developing like Knight to
D2 which I kind of like a bit better
very simply defending the pawn very
often when you're playing against a
Stafford and you have this sort of
structure it's sometimes safer to Castle
Queen side to ensure that black can't
get anything on the king side C5
okay bishop and pawn now form the
battery against D4 there are three
attackers I mean D5 is probably
[Music]
the the easiest move to to go
for yeah if I take then I'm kind of
allowing the bishop to find some
life so let's go for Pawn
D5 I'm gaining a little bit more
space I mean it's possible black will
play
C4 or maybe C6 and try and break apart
my my Pawn
Center and even though the position is
good for white like it's still takes
work to
win like even though I have a bunch
of
bunch of nice types of advantages it's
not game over just yet black is
preparing to Castle
queenside I might go over the same I
might go over Queen C2 and queenside
Castle I'm still not in any rush to take
the Knight I mean I could consider
grabbing another Pawn
but I think that's a little bit too
materialistic yeah go for Queen
C2 and I am giving black the chance to
Castle after which maybe then I can play
E5 I'm going to have to
calculate E5 looks like it wins material
like I attack the Knight which is now
pinned to The Rook but if I play E5
there's Queen takes
D5 and then that in turn pins my Pawn to
the undefended bishop
yeah still
tricky probably just want to Castle
here like no reason to play E5
and make a big
mess if I Castle everything is still
pretty harmonious pretty well
defended but I do want to be constantly
looking for for tactical ideas like E5
is still on the radar also the Queen and
King are aligned on this diagonal so
want to look for ways to maybe get a
bishop to G4 or
F5 not going to happen soon
though it's a useful move getting off
the diagonal applying pressure to the E
Pawn I considering Bishop D3 briefly but
then that runs into
C4 and then I have to move back so
not the most productive
idea I think in a position like this I
want to ask myself what's my worst piece
and how can it be
improved and I think the simple answer
is this Rook so one piece that was not
really doing anything I'll be happy to
support the pawn in the
center and maybe the plan is to play
like Bishop F3 and eventually get an
E5 I'll play Bishop F3 here
like even though the Bishop's not doing
much it's kind of blocked in by the
pawns it does help reinforce things well
maybe make E5 possible because I I do
unleash the
Rook another
idea probably very soon is this move
C4 and maybe I could could have
considered it last few moves but C4
would be nice in blockading Black's C5
Pawn also reinforcing
D5 I'm going to go for
it and it's well supported by the
Knight and basically what I'm doing here
is I'm over defending the D5 Pawn so I
would really like to
push especially in this case now that
black has closed down the queen side if
I
push I'm almost trapping the Knight
a knight has two safe
moves not the happiest of
squares I can move
back and so far this has been a
relatively like positional and
strategic game which is usually what you
want like when you're playing against a
Gambit you want to avoid all the
Tactical
messiness this game I basically just
grab the pawn in the opening
and
then just tried to play Super
solidly so far it's working out black is
gaining some space throw in the capture
and then I have Bishop E4 or Bishop
E2 think I like Bishop
E4 Pawn is still defended I create the
battery against the
Knight when the Knight moves I have
Bishop
F5 attacking the queen and the G
Pawn so life is pretty good
here we'll take the
pawn I did burn a lot of time explaining
the opening but uh it's still over 3
minutes probably have to up the pace a
little
bit and going forward I think a nice
plan would be to play F4 I keep gaining
space Black's offering a
trade do I want to
trade yeah I might as well
trade given the time situation given the
fact light's up two
pawns now I might as well put the Rook
back on H1 like The Rook served its
purpose on E1 helping the pawn Advance
now that H files open
Knight's attacked black counterattacks
the
bishop so if I take it's basically a
trade but I could win the pawn in the
[Music]
end another idea here is to play Knight
E4 and just
centralize which honestly I like
better like I'm almost threatening
probably am threatening Rook to takes H7
then
Knight F6 if I want to be
fancy but really just going for full
domination this Knight can't really move
his Knight f8 leaves a rook
hanging and in the meantime if I take
take here take and that's just a kind of
big trade
looking at this move
D6 then of takes I take with the fork
against a king and
Rook this bishop is really out of it
completely boxed
in okay I'm going to play Queen
D3 even though this walks into a pin the
idea is to play Queen
D5 I'm also over defending the bishop so
it gives my knight some more
Mobility
ooh okay I'm not going to hold back
let's play
F5 there probably a lot of good-looking
moves but the idea here is if Queen
takes then I take on C5 and win the
queen so it's a nice example of oh no my
Pawn I didn't really say it in time but
uh opponent took the
bait now the position is finally
crumbling for
black be winning the Knight next
move there's also Queen D5 but think I'd
rather win some material
first and this is madeen
one okay
so honestly I was not expecting to face
a Stafford Gambit at this rating level
but uh I mean my opponent maybe I'm
curious if my opponent has like watched
some of my videos or how they learned
the
opening uh if we just go
through I'm hoping this is a nice
example of like how to play against a
Stafford like very simply D3 Bishop E2
uh preventing most of the
shenanigans H3 I will say in this
position if I was playing Black the move
I like to play is Queen to
D4 and this is still tricky
because F2 is a big Target and if
castling there's a line Queen D6
preparing Knight G4 and there's a lot of
tricks that can still arise from this
position like it's actually kind of hard
for white to stop Knight
G4 so if I ran into Queen
D4 the move was going to play is Rook
F1 even though this violates a principle
of like just giving away casting rights
now putting the King on G1 the king is
just safer in the center for the time
being and then the plan is to uh of
course defend F2 and then gradually play
C3 and develop the bishop and then the
Knight and eventually Castle Queen side
and um yeah this position I've
encountered from the black side before
it's only like pretty strong and
experienced players who who know this
move um but if yeah if I encountered
this I would have played Rook F1 and it
would have been still objectively good
for
whites so going forward and what
happened in the game I think uh yeah it
was just a matter of being solid
grabbing space following principles
getting some peace
Harmony grabbing more space and then
eventually I had some tactics winning
other
pawn and then eventually yeah setting up
this nice tactic with the discovery uh
if black doesn't blunder the queen like
Queen D7 was probably a better
try it's white who's having all the fun
like Queen D5 check was coming and maybe
E6 to follow so um yeah it was a happy
game at least for
me so I'm realizing it's already like
kind of already deep into the recording
like after 15
minutes um so I think what I'll do is
end the episode here it's um I don't
think I've had a single game episode but
I think there's some nice instructional
value from this game especially playing
against the Stafford hope you guys
enjoyed it if you have questions leave
them below and stay tuned for the next
one in which I'll hopefully actually be
breaking 1,000 ELO so I'll see you guys
then